よろしくお願いします
これは何回も もしかすると皆様に申し上げたかもしれませんだけど
自分の国のお寺のそばに家がありまして
その家の主人というか男性がいて
彼が仕事は退職して何もしないで家に退職金で生活しているんです
それで私は彼にもあんたも仕事もしないことで
日曜日ぐらいお寺に来たらどうですかと
いろいろやることもあるし
法事やらいろんなことをしますから
説法とかね そういうものも参加したり
協力したりしたらどうでしょうかと
ちょっとまあ 一応秒で寺に来られます
秒もかからないんです
それぐらいそばですけど
彼の答えは まあそう言ったっても暇がないんだよ
何と言ったら 牛一頭飼ってるんだからね
その牛を 牛をあっちこっち持って連れて行って
餌を草を食べるためにね
まあ一日何回も連れていかなくちゃいけない
言われた途端 ああそうと言って
私はそれで話をやめたんです
まあ骨だらけのもう痩せている
何の役にも立たないもう牛なんですけど
で まあ向こうは牛っていうのはいろいろ仕事をさせたりしますからね
まあそういうこともできない
痩せているオスで 当然仏教徒だからね
肉に売るわけにはいきませんしね
だからその牛の価値で
まあ法を聞いたり修行したりとか
そんなことはできませんという話ですよ
だから自分の人生よりも
道徳を学ぶよりも 真理を勉強するよりも
牛の方が価値があるんですよ
だから人間の理解能力っていうのはそれぐらいのことで
仏典では いわゆるその場合はね
その人をからかうべきなんですけどね
まあそういうふうに他の人もからかうストーリーっていうのはありますけどね
で じゃああんたはね  その牛と一緒に地獄に行く場合はね
まあ牛はありがたかったんですよとね
天国に行けるよというふうにね
まあ閻魔様にでも言ってみなさいよというふうに言うべきところでしたけども
何も言わなかったし それっきりこの人には話はかけませんと
とは言っておいたんです
寺に来ることはありますけどね
まあだってあまり私はもう相手にしない
まあ牛と一緒に言ってくださいと
行きたいところにという感じで
またまあ もう一つ 人に
いろいろこのもう仕事はね
手伝ってくれというふうにね
お寺のことでね 頼んだんですけど
その人はお坊さん 日曜日でしょ
日曜日は全然もうお寺に来られません
なんで休みでしょうと
だからもう日曜日は私は洗濯物をしたり
庭のいろいろ掃除をしたりしなくちゃいけないんだと
ああ そうですか じゃあいいですよと
それでも終わっちゃったんです
それふうに価値をはっきり言われると
もう二度と私だったら言わないんですね
だからまあ 一般的に考えてみてください
何かね 洗濯物あるんだからって大事な仕事をしないとかね
村のために みんなのために
村の一員としてやるべき仕事をしませんと
なぜか洗濯物あるんだから
それは公で言えるもんでしょうかね
例えば寺の用事なんかでみんなを集めたところでは
みんなのことをお互いに知ってますからね
もし私がね 何々さんにも一応お願い広告はしたんだけど
洗濯物あるんだからって来られないんだってと言ったら
その人の立場って何なのかとね
まあそれはどうせ言えないんだからまあ言いませんけど
もし言ったならばね ですから
人間というのは物の価値知ってますかと
明らかにこのくだらないものに
どうでもいいものに 自分の大事な人生を無駄にしているんですよ
だからなんとか人間の形をとって生まれてくるんだけど
まあ動物の精神で死んでしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この評価してみるということは
知識のある人 知恵のある人っていうのはいつでもしなくてはいけない仕事なんです
人生っていうのはもう選択
選択 選択ばっかしで いろんなものを選択しなくちゃいけないんですよ
1分以内で我々にとってはいくつかのやりたいこととやらなくてはいけないことっていうのはいくつかいつもあるんですよ
すべて決まりきっているわけではないんです
7時10分で朝ごはん食べますといったら
人類みんな 7時10分で朝ごはん食べますかね
まあ呼吸しなくてはいけませんと言ったら
まあそれは人類みんな生命はほとんど呼吸していますよ
そういう場合は選択はないんですね
まあかえってそんなものには別に時間というものを取りませんよ
ちょっと待ってください
明日仕事を休ませてくださいって
なんで？明日ちょっと呼吸しなくちゃいけないんだよっていう話はないでしょうに
でも明日 うちの子供が結婚式だから仕事を休ませてくださいということは言えますけどね
その場合は選択は成り立つのですよ
仕事に行くか 自分の子供の結婚式に行くかという
で 同時に時間取っちゃいますよ
時間も取ってしまう だから仕事に行っちゃうと結婚式に行けなくなっちゃう
結婚式に行ったならば
仕事には行けないんですね
だから ある決まっている時間である 1つ仕事しかできないんですね
でも本当は仕事 2つあるんですよ
だから選択しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 普通の世界でこのもうアポイント
アポイントを取っちゃうとね
まあ三つ四つぐらい同じ時間に取っちゃうと
もうものすごい嫌われるでしょうに
すごい信頼性ない人やとかね
でも結局 我々の人生で我々はそうやってアポイントっていうのは同じ時間でもう随分たくさんあるんですよ
やらなくちゃいけないこと
ですから ある時間で そのアポイントはたくさんあるんだけど
どちらにするかと決めなくちゃいけない
残りを捨てなくちゃいけないんです
もうできません 残りは
もう時間過ぎ去ったんだからね
結婚式終わってから じゃあ仕事に行くんだぞっていうことは成り立たないでしょうに
もうその日は終わっちゃったんだから
だから一つか二つか多数か
もうきれいさっぱり捨てないと
だから ある一つの時間間隔で一つの仕事しかできません
というわけで この評価してみる
価値を決めるということは
生きる上ではものすごい必要なことなんです
でも 残念なことに 牛のお世話をしなくちゃいけないんだからといって
人間として まともな人間として
必ずしもやらなくちゃいけない仕事は全部もうダメというんだから
そこでこの価値の判断というのはいかがでしょうかと
例えば子供はゲームやりたいんだから
学校に今日は行きませんと
と決めることとは同じでしょうに
私は学校を休みますよ
なんで？と聞いたら 今日は一日中ゲームやりたいんだと
だから その場合でも選択ですよ
ゲームやるか学校に行くかというね
子供が一日中ゲームやりたいんだから学校に行きませんと言ったら
大人が偉そうに怒るんだけど
では我々大人が正しい判断していますかね
もし我々はこの一本ごとに
瞬間瞬間ごとに出てくる多数の仕事の中で
正しい選択をして判断して生きているならば
もう人生には問題ありますかね
問題っていうのは成り立ちませんね
だから ありとあらゆる人生には
人間には世の中でいろいろ問題があるとするのは
この選択を間違ってますね
いわゆるやってはいけないことはやってしまった
選択してはいけないことは選択しましたということになるんですね
そういうことで 我々にはいろいろもう大変なトラブルやら苦しみやら
いろんな問題っていうのは生まれてくるんですね
そういうわけで まあ私たちにとって一番大切なっていうのは何なのかっていうことは
平和で幸せで 生きる上では必要なことなんです
いわゆる欠かせないものなんですよ
そういうわけで 初期仏教というか
お釈迦様の教えではね
まあ人間にこの物事を判断する能力っていうのはあってほしいと
なかったらもう大変なことやと
物事をきちんと判断する
いわゆる判断といっても
評価してね 評価することであって
どちらにするかという選択することですけどね
そういう客観的な判断なんですけどね
それはどうしても必要ですよと
そういうわけで この判断能力をなんか放棄して
他人に任せて生きていることは
愚か者の無知な人の生き方だと
守られてるんだからいいんじゃないかとかね
まあ今日はちゃんとお祈りしたんだから一日大丈夫やとかね
あるいは人間というのは生かされていて
自分で生きているのではないんだと
というふうな物事を考えちゃうと
かなりだらしない人間にはなります
自分で責任を持って判断しようとはしない
生かされているんだからね
ありがたく もしありがたく生かされているんだったら
人にはトラブルないでしょ
このありがたく生かされているんだぞと言っている人々にもにも
やっぱりがんになったり
病気になったり 親しい人々が死んじゃったり
損したりとかあるんじゃないの
面白いことに この悲しい出来事に出会うたびに
災難災害に遭うたびに
その気持ちが強くなるんですよ
生かされているんだからしょうがないと
あの思考って何でしょうかと
私がちょっとなんかわからないんですけどね
これ親しい人々やら親戚やら家族やら
もうみんな何か災害とか災難に遭っても死んじゃったと
これ耐えられないほど悲しいなのに
大丈夫 生かされているんだからと
というふうに思っちゃうんですね
だからまあ とにかくそういう
いわゆるこの何かに頼る
依存するということは
仏教でなぜないかというと
頼って依存して助けてくれるでしょうと
守ってくれるでしょうと
管理してくれるでしょうと
導いてくれるでしょうと
幸せにしてくれるでしょうと
死んじゃったらもうみんな一斉にまとめて天国に入れてくれるでしょうと
という思考っていうのは
明らかにだらしない人間を作るための
怠け者を作るための考え方なんですね
いわゆる怠け者万歳というね
機嫌取りだと思いますよ
一般の大勢の人々のね
それで誰でも人っていうのはもう 100%怠け者ですよ
人間っていうのは怠けたいんですよ
まあそれは正直な話 皆様方は認めたくないと思いますけど
やっぱり事実はそうなんです
で 認めたくない方々は私だけ違いますよと一人で思えば楽です
私にとっては 大体ではなくて
人間っていうのは怠け者ですよ
怠けたい それを読まれた人が怠け者万歳の教えを教えちゃうと
もう大勢の人々はまあそれ
こそ真理だという風に飛びかかっちゃうんです
そこはもう世の中の歴史
ですよ で それで人類っていうのはもうかなりいろいろ苦しんだりしているんです
だから私たちは何を探し求めているかというと
この怠けることを正当化する教えを探しているんですよ
で あの いろんな宗教でね
仏教にもありますけど
このいろんな宗教でこの天国というところの話があるんですね
この天国の話について読んでみてください
宗教はどうでもいいんです
仏教の天国の話でも キリスト教の天国の話でも
イスラム教の天国の話でも
どちらでもいいんです
この天国の物語を読んでみると
誰にでも読めない一つのこの下書きがあるんですよ
だから このものを読むときは
理解するときは いつでもこの表面の言葉だけではなくてね
この裏のこの心境 これを作り出した人は何を考えたかというところも読んでいただければね
大変ありがたいことなんですけど
なかなかそれはちょっとみんなやらないんですね
表面的な言葉の意味だけ取って黙っているんですね
だから まあちょっとこの下書きも読んでみたらどうでしょうかと
この天国というのは まあ私は仏教のいろんな文献ではね
書いてる天国の話とかはまあ知っているんですからね
これヒンドゥー教の文化もすごい混じっているし
そこで天国に行けば 昔の言葉で書いているんだからね
まあ農業することは要りませんと
畑耕したりすることはいりませんというと
農民の人々はいかにありがたがるでしょうかね
農民 農業をやっている人っていうのは大変でしょう
ものすごい早く起きたりとかね
一日も一日もう大変きつい労働で仕事しなくちゃいけないし
で 昔ですからね それはこの植物を守らなくちゃいけないしね
動物たちから 虫たちからとかね
大変なんですよ 稲を刈りて籾を取って
もうすごい仕事 で 機械ないんだから考えてみてください
いかに大変かと もう想像できないと思いますけどね
あの 籾をね あれもう何て言いますか
この籾殻を取って米にしなくちゃあかんで
それは手でやる場合はどれぐらい大変かと
臼でね まあ何時間もやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
で 二 三時間仕事をしたら
もうやっと 1食の米が取れるぐらい大変な仕事なんですね
そういうふうに苦しんでいる人々に
天国に行けば まあ農業やらなくてもいいんだよと言ったら
どういう気持ちでしょうかね
あれほどありがたい話はないということになるんです
ですから 誰も天国に やっぱり何かそれやることなかったら面白くないんじゃないかという反論が出せませんね
で それで仕事をする必要はないんだと
天国では病気はないんだと
老いることもないんだと
年は取りませんと だからなんとありがたいでしょうかね
だからまあ そういうふうな話で
人々を何といいますかね
機嫌を取って 人々ので
生命のこの本来の怠けを応援するんですよ
今はしょうがない 仕事に行かなくちゃいけないと
今は病気になったってもしょうがない
こんなもうとんでもない人間になって生まれたんだからと
今度こそ天国に行って
全部もうきれいさっぱり終わりにするんだよというふうに気持ちになるんですね
だからこの天国に行きたがるという場合は
みんなそんなもんなんですよ
それはまあ仏教徒であろうか
他の宗教の方々であろうか
まあこれはもう関係ないんですよ
人間みんな同じなんです
だからお釈迦様の話は随分色が違うんです
だからそこら辺 私はずっと言ってますけど
まあ色が違いますよと
全くこの我々はこの固定概念で形取ってますから
この自分持ってる枠にはめるように語ってくれと言うんだけど
それが難しいんですよ
私たちの文化を壊すなよと
我々今まで考えてきた思考パターンを壊すなよと
そういう過激的なことを言うなよと
というふうに この教える私たちに指導をするんですね
学校には行きたいんだけど
先生は何をどのように教えてあげればいいかということは
生徒が教えてあげるんですよ
状態になるんです  そういう気持ちで聞いているんだから
もうなかなか話はいつまでも物別れで終わっちゃうんです
ですから このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
まあ色違うんですね そういう怠けばんざいではなくて
もう怠け反対なんですよ
仏教には怠けイコール堕落なんですよ
成長はないんだと 退化だよと
だから退化っていうのは苦しみということになるんだからね
だから この物事を徹底的に客観的に見なさいよと
それ客観的に見るということは
この至って簡単です 難しいことじゃないんです
ものすごい簡単なんです
だから この何て言いますか
物事をちゃんと客観的に見て判断して
怠けを攻撃して頑張ってみるといかがでしょうかと
だから客観的っていうのは
だから前の話の元にまた戻りますけど
ある 5分で自分には仕事を 10個ぐらいやるとしますね
だからこの 5分で これもこれもこれもというふうに
まあ塔ぐらいの仕事はあるんだと
でも一つしかできません
一つするためには もう例えば 5 分間かかるんだと
だからその塔ぐらいの仕事の中で一つちゃんと見て選べることでしょうね
選ぶことでしょうね それっていうのはそんなに難しいんですかね
7時 10分になったところで
朝ごはんの時間だと でも自分がシャワーもしなくちゃいけないんだと
だから ７時10分でシャワーにするか朝ご飯にするかということでしょうに
そんなに難しいんですかね
それ決めることは だから客観的に物事を見て
知恵でもって生きるということは
世の中で一番簡単なことなんです
この怠けばんざいの思考でずっと生きてきたんだから
地球の人類みんな 大変生きるということは難しい
乗り越えられない 大変な仕事になっているんです
だから生きるということは
もう朝飯前みたいな もうとっても簡単なものなんですよ
とってもとても簡単で
もうもうババ抜きゲームほども難しくないんです
そのゲームにしたっても
理屈成り立ってないでしょうに
何かカードを引くだけだから
だから合ってるか合ってないかっていうぐらいの話でしょ
だからそうやって運命任せの生き方っていうのは難しいんですよ
だから生きるということはそれよりも簡単なんですが
なぜできないかと それでまず言えるのは
この我々のこのもう怠け主義っていうのはね
まあそれはちょっともう直そうではなくてね
まあ理解するということは必要なんですね
そんな簡単に治るわけじゃないんですよ
だから私だけ怠け者ではないやと一人勝手に思ったっても
まあそんな簡単には治らないと思いますけど
ですから 生命っていうのは怠け主義で生きているんだということを理解してほしい
その理解納得のができたところで
もう淡々と生きていられる方法っていうのは出てくるんです
それでゆっくりと怠けも消えていくんです
それで私がこのよくチャレンジする
このまあポイント変えますけど
まあ一応人間っていうのは
まあそういうふうに判断して生活しなくちゃいけない
判断は自分でしなくちゃいけない
だから朝 ７時10分で朝ごはん食べるか
それを後回しにして先にシャワーするかとかね
これが神様が言ってくれますかね
ご先祖様でも言ってくれますかね
まあ試しにやってみてください
まあ日本では別に神様というよりは先祖崇拝ありますから
仏壇のところに線香を １つ立てて
おりんも鳴らして どうか教えてくださいと
私は ７時  ７時10分でご飯を食べるべきか
あるいはシャワー先にするべきかと
もし一回だけでも一生自分の一生で
神様かご先祖様か 誰かが教えてくれたのなら
ならば私に言ってください
私は話を変えます だから客観的ということは簡単でね
そういうことなんですよ
私たち知っている具体的な人生では
生まれてから死ぬまで一つ一つ自分で決めてやっているんですよ
たとえそれが正しかろうか悪かろうか
成功であろうが失敗であろうが
それと関係なく自分で判断してやっているんですよ
私が今まで知っている経験の中では
もう神様が来て言ったということはないんですけど
時々人々にいろんなことを言われる時もありますけど
やっぱりそれでも自分は自分で判断するんですね
あなたもなかなかいいことを言うんではないかと思って
自分が納得して ではそういうふうにするんだよと
うん ...ということで生きているんでしょうに
ですから 勇気を出して
あの たとえ我々の人類の古くからの文化で
こういう風な信仰とやらいろいろあるんだそうと言ったっても
それはちょっともう置いておいて
勇気を出して自分で自分のことを判断するんだよということをね
簡単ですけど 誰もやりたくないんですね
誰かに言われるならば
まあその通りにやるということは
まあ簡単便利で責任放棄で
もう言ったんだからやりましたよと
という言い方になっていますね
そういうことで この正しく判断するためには
大体我々は考えることが大事なんですね
ですから 仏教はこのヨニソマニスカラという思考パターンを
ヨニソマニスカラというこの思考の仕方を
まあ推薦しているんですよ
まあお釈迦様は で ヨニソマニスカラ
マニスカラっていうのは考えるということなんですよ
だから考えることは このもういい加減で好き勝手にするんではなくて
このヨニソっていうのは大変な
もう難しいというか もうそのまま我々が理解するもので
もういわゆる正しい思考という意味で取ってますけど
ヨニソっていうのは この
その因 因果法則に沿って考えるということなんですね
例えば こういうことがあると
こういうことになるんだよと
で きちんと客観的に目の前にある原因結果から考えるんですね
で すごいクールな考え方なんですけどね
で 我々は考えるときは
このヨニソマニスカラということっていうのは
それほどもう使わないんですね
で 好みで考えるということはよくあるんですね
で 自分の主観で考える
主義に基づいて考える
まあ例えば 絶対的に神様がいるんだと思った人が
すべて強引にその思考に合わせて考える
まあ例えば もうどこかに災難
災害が起きたとしますね
ああ それはもう神様が決めたことだからということで
それを強引にそうする
で あのイスラムの人々は
もうイスラム教を爆撃しているんだから
アメリカに神様が炭疽菌を送ったんだと
と思っているんですね
だから絶対的に神を信じているんだから
もう神様が我々イスラムの人々のみを守ってくれるんだよと
ですが 爆弾が落ちるのはその人々の頭の上なんですけど
まあそれはまあもう悪魔が戦っているんだということで解釈する
それは悪魔がやっていることだから
決して考え直す必要はない
それが悪いと それでアメリカで炭疽菌の出来事を受けて
みんな怯えているんですから
ああ なるほど 神様が我々のみを守ってくれると
そういうふうに考えるんですね
その人々にとっては それが理屈であって正しい思考なんですよ
でもそれはヨニソマニシカーラではないんです
ヨニソマニシカーラっていうのは
もうそのまま単純に考えることなんですよ
なんでアフガンにアメリカ人が爆弾を落としていますかというと
腹が立っているんだ 腹でしょ
アメリカ人が明らかに
なんでそんなに腹が立っているんですかね
あ これはもういろいろ事件が起きたんだから
単なるワールドトレードセンター
貿易センターを爆撃ではない
言わないね その場合はね
攻撃した それだけではないと
過去にもいくつかのケースがありましたと
そういうことで腹が立ってるんだと
それでなんでそれなのに我々に爆弾を落とすんだと
ああ なるほど 我々が犯人やと思ってるんでしょうと
では実際に犯人は私たちですか？と
そういうふうに考えることが客観的なデータから考えることなんですよ
それは一切使わない 爆弾を落とす
あ 我々イスラム人だからイスラム教に爆弾を落としているんだと
どうやってイスラム教に爆弾を落とせますかね？私はそれ考えたいんだけど
聞きたいんだけど 平気で言うんですね
アメリカが意図でイスラム教を攻撃しているんだと
別にイスラム教にはイスラム教というのは存在しないんだから
別に単なる考え方でしょうね
それはどこにも存在しないもんでしょうね
キリスト教をにキリスト教に爆弾は落とせませんよ
ですから この教えに爆弾を落としているわけじゃなくて
人間に落としているんですよ
人間の頭の上に で それでいつでも
まあこの戦争はイスラム教に対する攻撃やイスラム教に対する攻撃が
ですからもう聖戦しましょうと
地球のすべてのイスラム人がイスラム教を守るために立ち上がるべきですよとか
このテロたちはもう叫んでいるんですね
だからそんなやり方だったら
ずっともうどんどんその戦争が広げるんでしょうに
終わらないでしょう で
アメリカにすると いくら爆弾を落としても
もう狙っているビンラディンというのは捕まりませんし
イスラム教徒というのはどこかでその人は囲まっちゃうんですね
その国から逃げたっても
あのパキスタンででもちゃんともう隠しとくでしょうと思います
だからすごい金持ってるし
サウジアラビアの応援というのはものすごい裏でやってるし
だからもう必ず逃げられるんですね
そうするとアメリカがもう腹が立ってるんだからね
どんどんもうやっつけちゃうでしょうし
で それで広げちゃうんでしょうに
もしついでにアフガン
パキスタンにも一つ落ちましょうと思ったらどうなるんですかね
もうやがてバレると思いますけど
パキスタンはかなり応援しているんだっていうことは
まあバレるぐらいのことでもないんですけどね
で それでも世界戦争に広げるんであって
問題は解決はしませんね
だから この客観的に考えるということっていうのはそんなに難しくないんですよ
でも 人間が自分の主義でもう解説しようとする
この間 我々 3人でデンサで帰るときは
私は冗談で言ったんだけどね
まあだからアフガンのね
あの あのもうオスマントなんとかっていうね
大統領でしたっけね あのアホにね
みんな言ったんだから
仏像を壊すなよと で 何でしたっけ？あのバーミヤンね
これは世界遺産でしょうしね
ずっと昔からあったもの
あの仏像を壊すなよとみんな言ったんだからね
あのアホが壊しちゃったんだからね
もうこんなもんだよね
爆弾を それはもう決して事実ではないんですけど
仏像を壊したんだから爆弾を落ちるってわけじゃないんだけど
私もみんな思ってるような
この変な思考 間違ってる思考っていうのはいかに面白いかと冗談で言って笑っちゃっただけで
まあそれがそれは事実だと思ったら
また世にそうまなざしが変わるでなくなっちゃいますよ
だから我々仏教徒から見れば
仏像を壊すということはとんでもない
悪行でしょうに 罰が当たるんだよと
という解釈はしているんですよ
それでそれをアフガンケースで適用しちゃうと
バーミヤン仏像が仏像を壊しちゃったし
それでまあもう思い存分今味わってるんだと
もし仏教を信仰していて
仏教という信仰に思考を汚染されちゃって思考すると
そんな結果になるんです
そうすると仏教徒たちももうざまあみろという感じで
もう死んだってもしょうがないよという感じになることはできますけど
やっぱりどう考えたっても
そんな風に考えること自体残酷な思考でしょうに
だから たとえ仏教の思考に基づいてうんうんと考えたっても
世にそうまなずかりにはなりません
それは仏教徒の勝手であって
そんな思考は キリスト教の方々はそうは思ってないんだから
仏像ぐらい壊したってもどうったことないんではないかと
そちらも思っているでしょうに
そちらは違う考え方を持ってはいないと思いますけど
例えばキリスト教をもう何のそう意味ない
キリスト教を殺しましたと
だから今もう罰が当たっているんだという解説もできるし
そう言っちゃうとまた残酷でしょうに
だからヨニソマニスカラで見ればそういうことじゃなくて
アメリカ人を殺しちゃったんですよ
そこで巨大な力を持ってるもう大国アメリカのパイどけひすいちゃって
ものすごい もうもう人を殺しちゃったんだから
腹が立って爆弾を落としているといえば
もうヨニソマニスカラでしょ
別に それはキリスト教の人々を殺したからでもなく
バーミヤンの仏像を壊したんだからでもないと思いますけど
だからヨニソマニスカラっていうのはすごく客観的に
もう単純に考えてみる
例えば仏像を壊したんだから罰が当たるんだよと
簡単単純じゃないんで
そんなことを言う場合は
もし反論されたら あなたに他の証拠もありますかと
もしそれだけしかなかったならば
証拠になりませんよ 逆なこともあります
イスラムの人々は インドであった仏像っていうのをほとんど壊しちゃったんです
アフガン 中央アジア それからパキスタン
ものすごい仏教文化っていうのはものすごく発達していたんだから
カシミールなんかはもう完全に仏教の地方でしたでしょうし
全部誰が壊しちゃったんですかね
昔はひとかけらも残る寺なんかはもう潰しちゃって
だからもう仏教の寺を壊したんだから罰が当たるというならば
昔からもそういういろいろ例っていうのは必要なんですよ
だからあれは私の冗談の話なんですけど
バーミヤン仏像を壊したんだから
今大変なことになってるんだけど
それはいかに変な思考かということは理解してほしいんだから
冗談で言っただけで 真面目に言ったわけじゃなくて
だから もし私が真剣にそんなことを言ったら
だったらもっと昔  12世紀でイスラム教が罰が当たるはずではなかったと
13世紀をもう 4世紀でも
なんで当時で罰が当たらなかったんでしょうかとという議論も成り立つんですよ
だからこの人間っていうのはいい加減な物事を考えるんだけど
これほとんど当てにならないもう思考なんですね
だからトラブルが起きちゃうんですよ
だからすごく客観的に具体的に考えちゃうと
まあいとも簡単でわかりやすいことなんです
だから このイスラエルと何でしたっけ
このパレスチナの問題も解決しないのは頭が悪いんだから
単純に物事を考えられないんだから
タリバンの問題も解決しないのはそういうわけなんです
すごい単純に考えちゃうと
物事を解説する なんでアフガンはずっと戦争ばっかりですかというと
いろんな民族があって
でお互いにもう殺し合いやっている
それで一番凶暴なタリバングループがもう政権を強引に取ったというぐらいのことで
でもほとんど他の民族はそれを認めません
それで面白いことに 各民族が我こそ正しいイスラム教徒やとと言っているところなんですね
アメリカがイスラム教徒に爆弾を落としちゃうと
イスラム教も攻撃しているんだってことになるんだけど
イスラム教の同士で殺し合いやってることは正しいんです
だからどう見ても思考がおかしいでしょう
客観性はない 科学性がない
だから人類の問題に必要なのは正しい思考なんですね
それがお釈迦様がようにそうマニスカラと言って
全然宗教とか習慣 習慣とかね
感情とかは絶対使うなよと
例えば親子ども二人が喧嘩したところで
親が集めて審判をやる場合は
では正しい審判しますか
もう 99パーセント正しい審判しないと思いますね
こちらの親がどうやって自分の子どもが無罪やと言えるかというふうに
そういう思考でいろいろいろいろ考えちゃう
向こうの親も いや 自分の子は間違ってないんだよということにで
頑張っちゃうんですね
子供二人の喧嘩で誰が間違って誰が正しいということは全く出てこなくなるんですね
それでお互いに認めないんだからね
お互いにもう物別れで
喧嘩で喧嘩で どんどん結果としてはただの子供の喧嘩がすごい大喧嘩になってしまうんですね
それぐらいのことで 村人みんな喧嘩になる可能性もあります
お互いに別れちゃって
こちら側あちら側ということで
だからこの主観で思考が消えちゃうんです
信仰で思考が消えちゃうんです
思考が消えると そちらになるのは戦争なんです
苦しみなんです 物別れなんです
戦いなんです だからこの地球に一度も平和な世界がなかった
平和な時代はなかった
ずっとお互いに憎しみ合ったり
苦しんだり 嫉妬したり戦ったりしてて
もう苦しみから苦しみへ生きながら生活してきたんですよ
だから人間には明晰な思考っていうのはもう聞いたことがないんです
だから平和が欲しければ
幸福が欲しければ 心の安定が欲しければ
まあヨニソマニスカラで生きることなんですね
だから別に仏教というのは他宗教に対して嫉妬しているわけでもないし
腹が立っているわけでもないし
軽視しようと思っているわけでもないんです
だから この仏教で神を認めないということは
決して他宗教を非難することじゃないんです
信仰を認めないということは
別にもう他宗教に対してケチつけてるわけじゃないんです
ただ単に客観的に人類に幸福ということなんですよ
人類に平和 人類に心の安らぎというテーマを実現する場合は
何が問題でしょうかというと
人間の思考 が問題ですと
見てみれば 誰一人も考える能力がないんだと
それでこの民族という考えこと考え方がありますね
どんな国の民族も 自分こそ世界で一番だとストーリーを作っているんですよ
日本民族の話 この神話物語あるでしょ
あれ読んでみると 日本人こそ世界で一番なんです
他のみんな みんなもう関係ない
レベルダウンなんですね
そこで中国漢民族の民族物語を見てみると
いえ 違いますね 漢民族こそ人類の一番なんですよ
で そんなことでどんな民族も同じなんですね
韓国人に聞いたっても
モンゴル人に聞いたっても
インド人に聞いたっても
インド人に聞いてみたら
いえ インドこそ文化の始まりで
人類の の始まりで すべての大本はインドなんです
これで中国人の思考と合わせちゃうと
お互いに殺し合いやるんじゃないの？だから我々はそういうふうに
この民族的に考えるときでも
自分こそ完璧で唯一で
もう一番最高な存在だと思っていて
それで考えるたびにその思考に基づいて考えちゃう
日本の歴史書なんか書く場合は
その思考でごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ事実をごまかす
歴史書く場合は 公爵書でなくたっても
一般の学問的な歴史を書く場合でも
ずっとある事実全部隠す
隠して自分の言いたいストーリーを人間にアピールするために
機嫌よくもうみんな読んでもらいたく
もうからくりということをしちゃうでしょうに
だから ある人が実際に起きた出来事を知りたいと
科学的に歴史を知りたいと思っても
そんな歴史は誰も書いてないんです
西洋人書く歴史では 西洋人こそ世界で唯一な人間で
なんと素晴らしいかと書いているんですね
そんなもんで 世の中では世にそうまなず力がない
ですから 歴史勉強したっても
結果はお互いに憎しみ合うことになるんです
そこでアジア人が西洋の歴史を読んじゃうと
なんかえらい惨めになるんですね
アメリカの映画なんか見てください
いかに他の国 国々の人々をバカにして貶しているんでしょうかと
それをお金払って見るんだから
アメリカ人に勝手に見せればいいでしょうに
これはもうもう 300億円かかったそうと言ったら
なんでこちらでお金払わなくちゃいけないんですかね
それに 見たっても我々をバカにしているだけでしょう
あの真珠湾なんとかの映画
みんな見るでしょ もう出ていますか？わかりませんですけど
見てお金払ってください
それから惨めな思いで帰ると
だからまあ 思考が明晰じゃない
その人々はきちんと研究して
きちんとデータを取って書いているんだと
その嘘ですよ 昔 映画あった
イギリスとアメリカ なんとか合体の映画で
リトルブッダという映画があったんです
これはリトルブッダだから私は見ましたけど
まあこれお金払って見たかタダで見たか覚えていないんですけど
まあ両方やと思いますけど
ビデオも持っていましたしね
今はないんですけど どこかへなくなっちゃったんです
あれ見ると結構惨めになるんじゃなくて
腹が立つんですよ 何一つも事実はないんですよ
ただ アメリカ人の感覚で仏教といえばラーマなんですよ
ラーマ教なんですね だってインチキやってるんだから
ラーマたちが 呪文を唱えるは
祈祷をやっているわ マンドラを持っているわ
もうインチキもやりたい放題やってるんですね
そこで何をやっているかさっぱりわからないんだから
やっぱり神秘的な力あるんだよとみんな思う
それはようにそう思う力ではありません
そこでどうしてもチベットに中国人が入っちゃって
チベット人を追い出しちゃったんだから
もうアメリカの場合は難民の中で仏教徒といえばラーマの方々っていうのを数としても多いんですね
それでも神秘的な もうもういわゆるこのミステリーだから
ミスティシズムだから
神秘主義だから これ気に入っちゃうんですよ
なぜ気に入るかというと
キリスト教も完全なミスティシズムですよ
あのリアリズムと具体性の宗教じゃないんです
初めから嘘で始まるんだから
だってバージンが子供でしょ
男とも何の関係なく それはミスティシズムでなきゃ成り立たないんです
普通のリアル的な思考でいえば
誰か男と一緒にならないと妊娠はしないんです
たとえ遺伝の特突然変異だ
変異が起きても 女性のあれ
卵子がもう細胞分裂して人間になるということはあり得ないんです
だって遺伝子足りませんだから卵子の中で
だからキリスト教というのも
やっぱりもう初めからミスティシズムですよ
だからその人々はミスティック世界の思考に慣れているんですね
どちらが正しいと私はわかりませんだから
まあどうでもいいんだけど
ミスティシズムだから
ヨニソマニスカラで言えばね
まあミスティシズムには西洋人が慣れている
これ気持ちいい 奇跡とかね
すごい気持ちいい話を聞くと
そうすると 異教と違う文化のものを勉強してみたいなと思ったら
ミスティシズムを勉強する
行って自分勉強して 自分の今までやった固定概念をさらに安定してもらう
攻撃してもらうんじゃないんです
安定してもらう だからあのリトルブッダの映画でまあ明確にそれ
それからブッダの物語っていうのは
ブッダは歴史的な人物だから
どこで生まれて どこで大きくなって何々かっていうことはしっかりしています
父親 母親はしっかりしています
生まれた場所もしっかりしています
寿命はどれぐらいでしたか？どこで歩きます？それはもう歴史的な事実だから
それも捨てられません
それも強引にそれに繋げる
でも仏教では一人の人間死んで輪廻転生すると五
六人に分配するって話はないんですよ
たとえ魂のことを仏教は魂が信じていないんだけど
魂を信じている宗教にしたっても
魂が分離するんだよという話は成り立たないんですね
でも あの人は魂が分離するんですよ
なぜかというと 理由はわかっています
ヨニソマニスカラで見ると
あの映画はイギリスとアメリカの関係で作るでしょ
だからアメリカ人の立場がないと
アメリカ人が唯一の人物だと映画で言わないと映画にならないんだそうです
だから アメリカ人として死んだ誰かラマがもう転生しますね
でもこれはインドで撮影しないとまずいんでしょ
それでインド人っていうのはえらいプライド高いんですね
だからインド インド人もちょっと褒め立ててあげないとね
それでインド人一人とティベット系の一人とアメリカ人一人にして輪廻転生させるんです
魂を三文化にするんです
で それで仏教わからない馬鹿どもたちがその映画を見て
その通りだと仏教はと言って
我々から我々に質問すると
これどう対応すればいいか
もうおかしいというのもあまりにもおかしいんですね
だから自分の主観で世界にある話さえもねじ曲がっちゃうんですよ
ティベットの世界でも輪廻転生という話っていうのは
ヒンドゥー教系統でその通りに信仰しているんだけど
やっぱり魂は分離するという話はないんです
だからこの世の中で人間っていうのは
何かものを作ったりしよう
たとえ歴史的な映画か映画を作ったっても
その時の自分たちの好みやら金儲かるかないかとか
そういうものでストーリーを変えるんですね
だから私は言いたいのは
世の中でヨニソマニシカラということがありません
だからあの映画は仏教の人々はもうただまあもう全然気にしないんだから
まあ仏教徒結構落ち着いてますから
まあ勝手にしなさいと
で アホじゃないかと それで終わりますからね
もし仏教の人々がこれが仏教を侮辱してくれることしてくれるすることやとというなんとか攻撃したならばね
これでもう喧嘩になるでしょうに
で 喧嘩にならなかったし
もうかえって仏教の人々はそれにお金を払わなかったんです
その映画に だって見なきゃいいでしょうに
仏教を知らない人々は見たかもしれませんしね
まあだからヨニソマニシカラっていうのは平和の教え
主観で感情で文化で民族思考で
物事を考えるということは危険な道で
戦争の道なんです それが結構客観的な事実なんです
だから神云々ではなくて
死後云々ではなくて そんなことより先に
なんで君たちに平和でいられないかと
というヨニソマニセカラの質問は仏教から出したいんですよ
天国にはしごを作る前に
あなたにお互いに仲良くすること
兄弟仲良くすることさえもできないでしょうに
それぐらい能力のない人はどうやって天国まではしごを作れるんですかね
ですから ブッダの道っていうのは
この人間っていうのは
その日から幸福になるために
そのその実践したその日から平和が成り立つために
心の平安安らぎを得てくるために具体的に語ってるんです
だから ちょっと心を清らかにして
ちょっと軽くして単純にしていただければ
そちらに平和があるんです
人が喧嘩を売ってきたら
単純に私は喧嘩嫌だからと
それで終わるんですよ
喧嘩は でも我々そうじゃない
あなた勝手に喧嘩を売るっていうことはとんでもないことではないかと
私は何もしていないのではないかと
あなたに対しては なんであなたのそんな大事で喧嘩を売るんでしょうね
私は何も悪いことをしていないんだかと言って喧嘩するんだったら
それ悪いんでしょうに
だから単純にまああんた喧嘩を売りたいんだけど
私は喧嘩したくないんだからやめます
言っただけで一人で喧嘩できませんでしょうに
あるいは怒って叱ってくるとね
まああんたはもう叱ってるんだけど
私はそういう喧嘩に参加したくないんだから
今忙しいんだから 明日いかがでしょうかと
一応アポイントを取ってくださいと
そこで喧嘩したいアホにアポイント取って
じゃあ明日３時に来ます
明日３時に来て もうガチャガチャと叱ることできますかね
できないんでしょうね
ちゃんとアポイントに来るんだから
だからちょっと単純になれば
少々少々ではない もう単純になればそちらに花が咲いてますよ
人類に だからお釈迦様はあの世を死ぬまで待つなよと
今すぐ言ってることは事実だとわかるんだよ
すぐ結果出ますよね そういうわけで
仏教で形而上学っていうのは捨ててるんですね
ヨニソマニシカラっていうのは
そういう風にお釈迦様を徹底的に優先する思考パターン
だからヨニソマニシカラというのは原因に沿って考えてくださいと
自分の好みで 価値観で
判断で 民主主義で 宗教主義で
感情で考えてはいけませんと
そういうものはすべて無駄で
時間のロスで不幸になるんだと
苦しみの道やと ヨニソマニセカラは幸福の道やと
ヨニソマニセカラする人に限って
ヤタブッタナーナっていうものは生まれるんですね
これが結果   このヤターブータニャーナっていうのは
この如実知見やと漢訳はありますけど
このありのままに真理を知る智慧っていう意味なんですね
ヤターブータっていうのはもうありのままにではよりももう起きたままになんですよ
出来事を起きてから知るんだからね
いわゆる普通の日本語で言えばありのままっていうことになっちゃうんですね
正しいにはありのままにではないんですよ
あったにしないと 起きたままに
ブータンっていうのはあったということを起きたという過去分詞なんです
ありのままで言えば現在分詞になりますから
その訳は違います だからガラスを割れる前にガラスを割れたことの知識は得られませんよ
割ったら割ったという割れたという智慧が生まれるんです
ですから ものが起きてそれを知る
ものが起きて起きて 次にそれを知るという順番です
それはもう科学的です
でないというならば  妊娠もしていない
結婚もしていない 女の人の子供に名前を付けたりすることできますか？出産届できますか？服買ってあげることできますかね
どうしてもできませんでしょ
まだ起きてないんだから
男も女も女も知らないんだから
出産届はできません だから物事は起きてから知る
ですからヤターブータ
それは日本訳でありのままというふうに訳して
それは普通の日本語になってしまって
あったままにと言えばなんかちょっと違和感を感じますけど
もうこの人は外人だから日本語がわかってないとか言われますけど
でもそれをあったままに知るっていうことなんです
それが解脱に導く智慧なんです
だからこのヨニソマナスカーラあれば
その日から その瞬間から我々は平和ですよ
憎しみ苦しみをやめちゃう
みんなで仲良くすることをできる
世界的な問題 国際的な問題
民主問題 何から何まで解決できる
でも国際スケールでは誰一人仏教を認めないんだから
まあこれは一応ありえないことで
仏教っていうのは嫌われる宗教だからね
怠け万歳ではないんだから
だからお釈迦様は個人個人
一人一人でも 知恵のある人はちょっと頑張ってみなさいと
教えは人類のために教えたんですけど
それ嫌だから みんな 我々にいかに苦しむかと教えてちょうだいとみんな希望しているんだから
いえ 幸せになれと言っちゃうと
いえ 違いますよと 私は買いたいのはそれじゃないんだよと言うんだからね
私は苦しみの方法を買いたいんだよと
あんた売ってるのは幸せの方法やと
ということで お客さんは来ないんです
だからお釈迦様は取った手段というのは
まあやっぱりこの公に語るのではなくて
各一人一人に教えてみて
その人が幸福に幸せになればいいんじゃないかなと
だからお釈迦様はいつでもヤタボトにアーナンダスターなだから
国民 人類に向かって喋っても一人も聞いてくれないでしょ
結果はゼロ 一人をこっち来いでと
君は苦しんでるんだよと
君が苦しんでいるのはこういうわけだよと教えたら
あ なるほど よくわかりましたと
だからその人が幸福になったならば
人類の中で一人が悟ったことになるんですね
だから結果ゼロにするか
1 でもいいんでしょうかといえば
価値判断でゼロよりは 1 の方がいいでしょうに
だから大衆の救い 語る教えっていうのは仏教ではないんです
大衆の救い語ると一人も救えませんというのはもうもう決まってるんです
個人で頑張りなさいというと
一人二人でも結果は出すんです
ですから  0 対 1 は 1 は勝ちますよ
そういうことで お釈迦様は個人個人に語るというようになっているんです
次にもう一つ言いたいことがありまして
このありのままは仏教だからといっても
日本人は固定概念ですごい誤解しているんだそうやと私にある人が教えたんです
あなた気楽にありのままとか何とか言ったって
我々はそれは理解しませんと
なんで？と聞いたら このありのままっていうのは
このありのままやとみんな思っているんだよと
ありのままというのはありのままとそのまんまやと
だから仏教は違う意味でずっと歴史的に語っているんだけど
結局みんなえらい自分の主観で誤解しているんですね
ありのまんまでいいやと
酔っ払いは酔っ払いでいいんじゃないかと
もうアホはアホでいいんじゃないかと
アル中はそれでアル中でいいんじゃないかと
それでありのまんまで
もう食べて飲んで遊んで
まあ後のこと気にしないでね
気楽に生きていることやと思って理解しているみたいですね
そのありのままではないんです
だから残念なことに ヤタブータっていうのは
日本訳も不可能ほど皆様の思考がヨーニソマナシからから脱出しているんです
ほとんど仏教用語はもう今翻訳不可能状態にまでなっているんです
ありのままっていうのは
この人類の怠けままを認めるわけじゃないんですよ
怠けでいいやと このまんまでいいやと
ありのままだから 余計なことをしなくてもっていいやと
ということで 私たちのこの生き方っていうのはね
まあ同じまんまで この苦しみのまんまでいいということにしちゃうんですね
だからそれじゃない すごいありのままっていうのはものすごい革命的な言葉で
あったままで知りなさいと言った途端
あんた方はあったままで知ってないんだよと
ということを言ってます
我々知ってる知恵はあってほしいままなんです
ありのままでもあったままでもないんです
あってほしいままなんです
だからアメリカに炭疽菌の問題が出てくると
パキスタン人があってほしいままに説明するんです
彼らが期待しているのは
神が罰を与ってほしいと
アメリカ人に 罰を与えてほしい
アメリカを粉々に潰してほしいと
という希望は期待あるんですよ
それを期待ですね 希望ですね
だから我々の知恵っていうのは希望のままということに知識というあってほしいままということなんですね
あってほしいままということは
決してありえないということでしょ
こういうふうにあってほしい
こういうふうにあってほしいということは
そういうふうにならないということでしょうに
そういうふうになるんだったら
別に希望を捨てなくたっていいんでしょうに
リンゴを買ってきて このリンゴ美味しくなってほしい
美味しくなってほしいと
バカじゃないんで そんなこと考えちゃうと
ご飯食べながらこのご飯がおいしくなってほしいなとか期待しません
もうとにかく自分作ったご飯だから
自分の口に合ってるんだから
美味しいのは決まってるんですよ
だから我々は期待 希望するのはないものなんですね
ないものをし これからも来ないものなんです
だから人間ってそこら辺よく理解してほしい
でもちょっと話複雑かもしれませんだけど
思考自体はね ありのままと言えば
我々はこのまんまだと思うことと
それから我々はそのままでなんとかと思ったっても
結局我々の知恵 知識はあってほしいままなんです
あってほしいままの状態は知識だと思っているんです
だから仏教にはありのままに知りなさいということは
ありのままに知らな知ってないんだよということで
だから歴史解説であろうか
もう世界経済状況の説明であろうか
マスコミの解釈であろうか
それをすべて自分の主観であってほしいままのということを説明しているんですよ
では 試しに言いますけど
経済評論家の話に乗って商売やってみてください
必ず損するでしょうに
経済学者の話に乗ってみてください
ダメです いろいろ推測したり
いろんなこと言ったり
誰にでもできることを言うんです
誰にでも言えることを言うために
もうものすごい もうもうもう国際
もう BBC やら CNN やらね
これ 1 分以内で喋って終わりますからね
一流の専門家が それどれぐらいお金取ってるかというと
そこら辺の小学生の子供に聞けばいいのに
だからこの世界っていうのはそんなもんで
結局事実知ってるわけでもないし
あってほしいままという状態を説明する
あってほしいままの状態を説明しているんだから
それに乗せられちゃうと
もうまた不幸になる 政治家の話に乗っちゃうと決まってます
ダメになるんだと 不幸になるんだと
ということで このありのままと言ったっても
少々考え直した方がいいんですね
厳しい話なんで ありのままっていうのは
だからあったままに知りなさいということは
もう出来事はこういう出来事が起きた
この出来事はこういう原因で起きたって
それで理解することなんです
それに証拠のない原因は出せないこと
この人はこういう薬を飲みました
それで今病気が治してますよと
ご先祖様にご先祖様に守られていたんだ
ですから 薬を飲んで治りましたと言っちゃうと
もうこれがちょっと困ります
なんでそういう風にすごい真剣真面目に言いますかというと
その人の場合はあった
ままなんですよ 病気になった時はご先祖様に守ってほしいという気持ちがあるんですね
気持ちがあるといろいろお祈りとかもする
でも患者さんはちゃんと治療も受けています
治療の結果で治ったっても
説明するときは医者に感謝ではなくて
ご先祖様に感謝ということになっちゃうんですね
それは知恵でも知識でも正しい考え方でもなくて
それはあった欲しいままの思考なんですね
あってほしいままの思考
だから世の中にあるのはあってほしいままの思考で
それは正しい知識とは仏教は言いません
世界は言いますけど だからよりそうマヌスからあれば
我々の思考がもっと単純になります
ものすごい単純になります
すごい軽くなるんです
それだけではなくて その瞬間から世界の問題
生きる問題 人間の苦しみっていうのは消えてしまうんです
今ある仏教のブッダの経典というのは
そのありのままの世界の説明なんです
皆様 経典を勉強するとか
何を勉強するかというと
ものすごい超越した智慧を勉強しているわけじゃ
そんなことを勉強しててわかりませんだからね
ただ お釈迦様が見たありのままの世界
あったままの世界 いくらやりなさいと言っても一人でできませんだから
お釈迦様はその事実を説明しているだけ
ある面ではそれ大きな教えですけど
自分でやれば同じ真理にたどるんですけど
だからそれもお釈迦様は言うんです
やってみればね 同じことだよと
誰にでもわかりますよと
まあ一旦話はまあそこら辺でちょっと休憩いたしまして
また始めます 始めます
ありがとうございます
参ります  それからこの
まあ我々にとって一番大事なものって何なのかということにまあ
話しています で 私たちはいろんなものに価値を入れてますね
ですから 私はよくチャレンジでいうことなんですけど
自分に持っている価値あるものとはリストアップできますかと
一番大事なものの順番で
もし一人一人の人が自分を持ってるものの
これが大事ですよと一つ書いて
あ これよりこれが大事です
リストの上に書く そういう感じで書いてみたらいかがでしょうか？と
もう紙に書くと まあ上上に書いたんだけど
これは真ん中といっても入りませんだからコンピューターだったら簡単に書けます
真ん中にでも挿し 挿し挿すことはできますからね
そういう風に優先順位を書けますかと
我々持っているものについては
それやってみると かなり何か発見できると思います
真理について 人間というのは
これも欲しい あれも欲しい
これにも価値があって
あれにも価値があるとかね
なんだかんだももう価値入れてあるんだけど
このぐちゃぐちゃ この優先順位を決めてないんですね
ですから かなり人生っていうのは複雑で苦しいんですよ
かなり苦しいんです 子供たちのポケットの中と同じなんです
子供たち持っている このもうもう何といいますか
カバンとか もうポケットとか調べてみてください
いろいろガラクタもいろんなものも入ってますけどね
で これも欲しい あれも欲しいとか
なんとかもう入れるだけのことであって
まあ子供だったら大人も同じなんですね
大人の家見たっても まあいろんなものはあるんだけど
なんでこんなものあるんでしょうかとね
とはないんでしょうしね
わかってはないんですね
ですから とにかくそうやって物を集まるということをやってるんです
で 優先順位あるならば
このどれが大事に守るべきですかと
どれがなくなっていってもいいんでしょうかと
どれがなくなったら困るべきですかと
そこら辺はしっかりするんですよ
それはもうないんだから
もう悩む人はもうもうもう何くだらないもの
ゴミがなくなったっても悩んじゃうということになっているんですね
それで物の価値って何なのかね
それも考えてほしいんですよ
なぜ物に価値があるんでしょうかと
で 私たちにこの質問を出してみればね
ダイヤの指輪と その道路の向こうにあるコンビニから買った弁当と
どちらに価値があるんですかね
で それでも決まってるでしょうね
まあ普通はね まあダイヤの指輪はもう 100万円もかかりますから
これは価値があって 弁当はもう 650円だから
まあそんな価値がないと
どちらにどちらを捨てるかというと
やっぱり捨てられるかというと
まあどうしてもというならば弁当を捨てますけどね
そういうことで やっぱり弁当より食べるものより
そういうダイヤに価値があるんですね
ダイヤの指輪よりはダイヤのネックレスだったらもっとすごい価値があるんですね
で カバンの場合は これはもうフランス
イタリア製になっちゃうとものすごい価値があって
日本製になるともう価値が減っちゃう
これは香港製だったらもっと減るという
で 品質はといえば もしかすると日本のものは品質はいいかもしれませんし
まあ香港でももう職人というのはいるんだからね
すごい手作りですごいいいものを作るかもしれませんだけど
その場合は このカバンの上に貼っている名前に価値が入っちゃうんですね
それで悪いことに これ
フランスのオーブンとかね
なんとかエルメスとか買っちゃいますけど
作っているのは中国ですけど
いろんなものをね だから偽物っていうのはね
全くわからない って言って同じところで作るんだから
だから中国製品嫌やと言っても
他の外国の会社のために中国で作っているものだったら
全然嫌ということではなくて
これは何々メーカーの何々ものっていうふうに価値を入れて随分威張って使ってますね
だから我々の価値観って何でしょうかね
何か意味ありますかね
そこでわかりますかね
なんでルイヴィトンとかね
あるいはシャネルとかね
そのカバンを持って これすごい高価なもの
価値あるもので 泥棒入ってね
もうそれ持っていっちゃうとすごい困るんですね
家に泥棒が入っても 冷蔵庫の中身を全部かっぱらって持って行ったっても全然平気で
泥棒が入ったら不安だわっていうことだけで終わっちゃうんですね
冷蔵庫はもう全くもう空にして全部持っていかれたと
でも冷蔵庫の上にあったシャネルのカバンはそのままやと
で 引き出しにあったアクセサリーも全然開けてもないんだと
という場合は もうただ泥棒が入ってなんか困ったなという不安だけで終わる
泥棒が冷蔵庫はかっ払うこと全然しないで
自分のカバンだけ持っていっちゃうと
これ大変なことで 大騒ぎで
ということになるんですね
ですから この我々の価値っていうのは
そんなに具体的で科学的
合理的かっていうよね
そこでなんでああいうものは価値あるかと
その有名なブランドというものとかね
価値あるかというと どこに価値がありますか？自分がすごいいいものを使っているんだそうと
最高の品物しか使ってないんだぞという見栄でしょ
威張る だから価値を作っているのは人の傲慢ですよ
人が持ってる見栄なんですね
知恵じゃありませんよ
だからこれは世界一高価なものをなんとかなんとかという場合は
その価値が物にあるんじゃなくて
我々の高慢にあるものなんですね
見栄というものにあるんですね
では 聞きますけど 人間高慢でかっこいいんですかね
見栄っ張りで みんなすごい見栄っ張りの人好きですかね
すごい高慢な人っていうのは友達にしたい？仲良くしたい？だからみんなに嫌われる
嫌に思われる性格なんですよ
そういうのは別に宗教でなくてもね
普通世の中の常識だから
見栄っ張りの人は嫌でしょうし
デマばっかり喋ったり
もうあれあれやこれやとかね
そういう人っていうのはもうすごいもう気持ち悪いんですよ
信頼もできないしね 見栄ばっかりの人だったら
だから友達にはもうしたくない
人々の位置になるでしょうに
それで人間の中で認められない性格
第一で物の価値を決めているんです
なんか変だと思わないんですかね
それは一つの世界の価値観
見栄と高慢 威張るために
で 同時に出てくるのは
あんたかというよりは
私はもう豊かですよと
私にはお金があるんだぞと
だから高価なものを使っていますよというところで差別心もあるんです
他をけなす気持ち それで人を差別して
人をけなして 人を軽視して
バカにして この世の中で幸せに生きていられると思いますか？世の中の戦争したっても同じことでしょうに
この相手の存在を認めない
イスラエル人がパレスチナ人の存在さえも認めないんですよ
人間としても見てないんで
だからずっともう苦しみで戦いで
どんな国でもイスラムの人々がいると
その国では戦争なんですね
なぜかとイスラムの人々は
たとえ数が少なくても他人
他の人々の存在を認めないんです
例えばインドネシアにしたっても
インドネシアじゃなくてフィリピンにしても
そういうトラブルがある
イスラーム人がもう戦うとか
ミャンマーにもある どこにでもある
自分の国でも戦ってなんとかぐちゃぐちゃしようとは一生懸命頑張ってるんだけど
仏教徒はもううまく戦えないようにと
もううまく機嫌を取っているんです
それで ごく普通の仏教の人々のは
知恵に勝てませんだからもう戦いたい
殺したいんだけど もうどうにもできなくて
でも仲良くはしているんですけど
それ以外も まあ来年 再来年あたりは何かやるだろうとは
なんとなくなんかそういう
まあ疑い 私にはありますけどね
どこでも問題作っちゃいますよ
なぜかというと その自分の宗教からはもう異教徒という概念があって
他の人間は認めないということがあるんですね
初期時代のキリスト教でもその問題あったんだけど
今はそれはないんですね
やっぱり人間尊重するということはあるんだから
そんなに問題は起きませんしね
ですから 世の中の問題にしたっても
この他を認めない 他人を認めない
他人を貶す 他人を軽視する
他人を差別するということっていうのは恐ろしいんですよ
苦しみのもとになるんですよ
それで私たちは個人個人で見ると
見栄 高慢持って高価なものを持ってますよとかね
高価なものしか買わないよということになってくると
そこで君たちにはないんだぞという気持ちもあるんですよ
ですから 物に価値を入れると同時に
我々は心の中の回転は徹底的に苦しみを作る
みんなに嫌がられる みんなから追い出される
思考がうじうじと回転しているのです
だから このようにそうマヌスカルで見ると
結構出てくる事実っていうのは
普段は出てこないものなんです
で 次に考えてみましょう
まあもう時間ないんだから最後のところに行きます
自分が住んでいるところで
日本だからこういう例使いますけど
まあこそこそといろいろ地震が起きたりします
まあ一応仮定しましょう
そこでそこら辺 地面を割れたり
いろんなちょっと危険ですね
である山みたいなところがあって
まあそこら辺は全く地震は起きないということになっちゃって
じゃあみんなそちらに避難しようと
でしたっても 場所が小さいんだから
もう何か持っていくものもないんだから
まあ一応高価な価値あるものを持っていこうかなと思ったら
家に例えば１０００万とか５０００万とか価値のあるダイヤのネックレスがあるとします
まあこれ持っていきましょうということで持っていく
これはもう地震で地割れして家倒れちゃうと
あれももう消えてしまいますからね
持っていく そこで周りが地震が起きて
例えば溶岩まで出てきたとします
外から人がもう近寄ることはできない
これで真ん中の山の中で
この逃げた人がそこでもうどうにもならない状態にいると
じゃあでは聞きますけど
その人はもう降りられません
あの まあヘリでなんとかすればいいって
そこはちょっとカットしましょう
でないと話が成り立ちませんだから
あっちこっちガスが出てきて
もうもう降りることもできませんし
誰も近寄ることもできませんし
自分がいるところにはもう一応安全でいられます
では あのダイヤのネックレスに価値がありますかね
あれがあれば安全ですかね
あの人は それでお腹が空くでしょ
夜雨が降るでしょうに
その時ネックレスありますから大丈夫やと
持ってるカバンはもうもう何と言いますか
もうもうなんとか まあシャネルだからいいんじゃないんですかということになりますかね
やっぱり避難する時は持ってくべきものは何でしょうかね
だからその場合は あのダイヤのネックレスどうなるんですかね
例えばもうかなりの森の中で遭難したとしたって
もういくら体にアクセサリーつけてあったってもね
これ役に立たないでしょう
まあ皆様もこのもし外国旅行とかで
あまりこのまあもうすごい金持ちの国々ではなくてね
随分自然もそのまんまで
自然の中で生きている
この単純に生活している
もう森やらそういうところに自分たち持っている
この文化道具をね 持って歩いてみてください
誰が馬鹿を見るんでしょうかと
すごい高価なネクタイとかつけて
インドネシアの森の中を歩いてみてください
そちらの山の中に生活している部族の人々と話し合ったりとかね
みんな驚いてくれますかね
あなたのネクタイは これすごいフランス製
イタリア製でしょうとかね
例えば森の中でもうまあもう生活している人々にただ腕時計あげたって意味がありますかね
これつけておいてくださいと
時々つけてるのテレビで見られますけど
あれは時間見るためじゃないと思いますけど
あれ見たらピカピカ光ってますからね
まあそれだけのことでつけてるんじゃないかな
何のための時間かと まあ我々には時計が必要ですけど
でもそこら辺にある時計はめてやってもなかなかもう価値がないんですね
今ももう 1,500円
2,000円でも腕時計売ってるしね
でもやっぱりそれはオメガとかね
ロレックスとか なってくるとどうでしょうかね
だから誰でもあなたはもう 1,500円の腕時計にするか
このロレックスにも 18 金のロレックスにするかといえば
もうすぐ 18 金のロレックスにするでしょうしね
だから価値があるかないかという風に見ると
どういう答えが出てきますかね
だから人間にとってどうしても欠かせないものって何なのかと考えたことがないんですよ
で 答えはこういう答えなんですよ
ロレックス時計にも価値があるんだけど
すごい一時的なんです
ある場面では価値があります
みんなもうすごい もうなんだかいろんな品物いっぱいあって
まあその中でも自分だけロレックス時計をつけていると
その時は価値があります
そこでボートに乗って海でも渡ろうかなと思ったところで
もう遭難してしまっちゃって
浮き輪にぶら下がっている時は
別にこんなロレックス時計っていうのはもうどうでもいいんです
チョコレート 1枚あればありがたいんですけど
その時は その時は誰かが来て
なんか変な人がそこの海の中でね
もう浮き輪につなげている人のところで
あんたもう３日間もう何も食べないで浮いてるでしょうと
じゃあチョコレート 1枚やりますけど
あげますからと でも交換やと
あんたのロレックス時計と交換するんだったらどうでしょうかと
言ったら その飢えて死にそうになっている人は
いや これは高いんだから冗談じゃないんだよと
こんな 100円のチョコレート１枚に何言うんですかと言いますかね
その時はそれをはすっちゃってチョコレート取って食べないと
だから物の価値っていうのはそうやってこの時空関係によって変わるもんですよ
金には価値がありませんよ
金っていうのは単なる金属なんです
みんな金属文化の中に生きているんだから
金に価値があるんであって
よりそうもの世界で見れば
スチールの方がもっと価値がありますよ
包丁もスチールだからね
の中で もうなんかもうそういう風に遭難状態になったっても
包丁があればなんとか切ってなんとかして食べることできますよ
ロレックスではできません
ダイヤのネックレスでは何もできません
そちらのウサギか何かやもうもう動物が来たっても
ネックレスを見せて その動物を殺してもう食べたということはないでしょうに
もし包丁ぐらい持っていたら
刺してそれをこうして食べて
なんか命をなんとかすることはできますけど
だから 場合によって家の包丁もダイヤのネックレスよりも価値がある時ありますよ
命を助けてくれる時があります
それから このこう無意味な価値を入れることによって
我々は巨大な恐怖感を味わっています
家にこういう何千万円の宝石とかね
置いておいて気楽に寝られますかと
ですから 物に価値を入れるということは
我々は自分の心の安定
平安というのは熟睡することは否定するんです
寝られないんです 一生怯えなさいという
という結果にもなります
ですから まあまあ もう全部話に縮めますけど
物には本来は価値がないんですよ
その時その時 価値が一時的に成り立つ
宝石なんかは高い値段で売れる時もありまして
全然売れない時もあります
日本で何年か前で ものすごい売れるんですよ
すごく売れた時期があったんです
もうこのなんていうデパートとかね
宝石の部分がすごい大きく
で 後で時期が出てきて
宝石屋さんはいるんだけど
一人もお客さんはいない
私はある日 ある宝石屋さんのところに行って
もう何時間ももうもうもうもう喋って喋って
私はもう帰りたいと言ったら
あいつはもう帰してくれないんですね
あの人は 別に誰も来ないんだから
そういう風なものなんですね
ある時は価値があって
ある時は価値がない 昔はね
水に価値があったんですかね
今どうですかね みんなミネラルウォーターで買って飲んでるでしょうに
そこで今ただというものはどんどんただでなくなる可能性もあります
今は空気にお金を払ってないんだけど
それでも払うことにもなっている場合もありますしね
空気清浄機やらね いろいろ使わなくちゃいけないことになっているんですけど
その場合は空気にもお金を払っているんです
これからよりみんな発展しますから
この地球は 科学発展やら何から何までみんなすごいんですよ
それでこれからは空気にもお金を払う時期が来るでしょうね
店で空気を買う と 買ってつけて使うと
ということになるかも
なる可能性もあります
ですから 物にっていうのは絶対的な価値がないんです
だから この優先順位を決めましょうと言っても
かなり苦労すると思いますよ
その智慧がないと では価値って何なのかというと
まず我々は生きるためにいろんな物質に頼らなくちゃいけないんですよ
生きるためにご飯を食べなくちゃいけないんですね
病気になったら死んじゃいますから
薬を飲まなくちゃいけないんですよ
寒い時は何か着なくちゃいけないんですね
毛が全部落ちちゃったんだからね
まあ猿みたいに毛はいっぱいあったならばね
自然の毛皮コートでよかったのに
もうないんだからね 動物を殺して動物の毛皮を奪わなくちゃいけない羽目になっているし
まあそれは置いておいても
我々服を着なくちゃいけないんですね
大体かなり価値あるのはそちらなんですよ
寝る時はちょっと場所が必要なんです
歩きながら寝られません
ですから 歩くためには人の場所でもいいんですよ
道路でもいいんです 歩く場合は
寝る場合は場所が必要なんです
で 食べ物は必要ですし
服も必要でしょうし 薬っていうものは必要でしょうし
いくらか価値あるのはそちらなんです
それ満たすとどうでもいいくだらないことに徹底的に価値を入れるんです
それに我々は戦うんです
嫉妬 憎しみ 何でもするんです
だから この豊かになるっていうことはすごい恐ろしいことで
だからアメリカにとってはいくらお金があっても足らないんですよ
例えば 送迎ミサイル計画やらね
もう宇宙から人を殺す計画は
何から何まで武器ばっかり開発しなくちゃいけないんだから
自分の民を守るために
別にアメリカ人を殺してやるぞと
この変な人しかは誰も思ってはないんだけど
別に関係ないんだから
そちらそちらでこちらこちらでいればいいでしょうに
でも余計な価値で余計な世界
地球の財産 自分一人占めに一人占めにしてちゃうと
プライドと見栄っていうものは出てくる
そのプライドと見栄のために
もうものすごい武器開発しなくちゃいけない
それにはすごいお金がかかる
そうするとまだ足らなくなります
まだもう搾取しなくちゃいけないことになるんですね
だから この世界戦争やらね
もう原子爆弾やら恐ろしい殺戮の武器やらね
そういう風な このもう歪曲された価値観
価値でないものに価値が入れているんだから出てくるんですよ
どうしても否定できない価値っていうのは
この衣食住薬ですね 着るものと食べるものと住むところと薬でしょうに
それでいくらか着るものがあると
もっといいもの もっといいもの
もっといいものとなってくるんですね
それでやがて着ても裸そのまんまなんですけど
これはブランド製品ですよ
1着は 1,000万円ってあるんですね
この 1着 1,000万のもの着てるんだけど
本当にあれ服やと服かと聞きたいところ
いくらでもあるでしょうに
歩けない 座れないとかね
それで人類は幸福になるんじゃなくて
ものすごい苦しんじゃうんですよ
まあそこら辺はこの価値の世界でね
物の評価するというところで考えてほしいんですね
それからまた人間のことに戻りますけど
まあみんななんとなく言うでしょ
命はすごい大事ですよとかね
命はもうお金で 計算できませんとかね
言うのは言うんだけど
どうですかね 我々の生き方は
お金のために人を殺しているでしょうに
土地のために人を殺しているでしょうに
だから価値観なんていうのは狂ってるんですよ
もし人間の命は尊いと思うならば
いくらお金があっても殺さないはずなんです
強盗しようと思ったっても
この人を殺さなきゃ強盗できません
やっぱり殺してはいけません
だからといって強盗しないで帰るはずなんです
それはありえないんですね
だから この人がね 誰が今世の中で起きてるこの戦争状態も
いくら正しいと言ったっても
やっぱり私たちは戦争が良くないんだと
人を殺してるん 死んでるんだと
どんな理屈つけたってもね
何のために殺すかというと
これ本当にもうそれ価値観が狂ってるんだからなんですね
だから 住むところがなんとかできたところで
もっといいところ もっといいところという風になってくるんですね
どんどん二人が家を作るんだけど
部屋数も 40個あるとかね
スイミングプールが 2つあるとか
住んでいるのは二人だけなんですけど
そこまで大きくなる それで誰かがそれに嫉妬して爆弾でも起こしたらどうしようかと
また警備からいろいろものをしなくちゃいけないと
で どんどんもうひどい状態になっていくんですね
だからこんな乱れた歪んだ価値観でなくなるのは平和と心の安らぎなんですね
ものすごい豪華な家を作っちゃうと
もうこれの管理やらそれを守ることで
もう大変な苦しみっていうものを味わわなくちゃいけないんですね
時々起こるんだけど あまりにも財産を持っていて
申告するときはもう忘れちゃう
こんなものありましたか？自分には
とかね それで申告漏れだと思って
これでまた恥までかけられちゃうんですね
わざと申告漏れしてるケースは別ですけど
時々忘れちゃったということもあるんですよ
何か収入あったんだけど
そのままどこかにもうそれはもう忘れちゃって
ありすぎだからって申告するときはそれもう忘れちゃったと
それでもその場合は アメリカと日本というのは厳しいんですよ
人殺したっても親切にしてくれますけど
申告漏れはそんな親切にしてくれません
人殺しよりはもう大変厳しいです
そういうふうなことにもなりますよ
だからまあ 本当に我々は心の安らぎっていうのは失っちゃうんですね
それでまあ あまり今日は別なポイントを説明しましたから
もうもう全部ギリギリと省略していますけど
あの 家族は大事だと 次のポイント
子供のためだったら死んでも悔いはないとかね
と思ったりする その場合はなんとなく表面的に見えるんですよ
自分が自分の命よりも他人の命を大事にしているんだと
あれは本当かと 自分のためだったら死んでも悔いはないという母親の父親の言葉っていうのは本当かと
なんで我々は家族を大事にしているんですか？なんで奥さんを大事に
なんで旦那を大事にしているんですか？あまり大事にしてないみたいですけど
とにかく一応ついでに言いますけど
で なんでそうやって家族を
にしているんでしょうか
実際にはね 例えば子供がもうなんかボートで落ちちゃって溺れようと思ったらところでおじいさんが飛び込んじゃって
まあもう脱走することおじいさんが死んじゃったとかね
ということはあるんだけど
で 自分犠牲になったっていうことはまあまあケースはありますよ
でも正直なところはどうでしょうかと
自分が死の死を覚悟して守ってあげるんですかね
その場合でも という問題が出てくるんですね
ただ泳げないで溺れただけで
まあどうしても見ていられないでしょうね
例えばおじいさんが水に飛び込んじゃっても
だからおじいさんで誰でもない私がそんなこと見ても
人が溺れるところを見ていられないんだから
もう何とかしますよ で
なんとかするんだからといって
やっぱり自分が死んでもいいんだから
もう助ける 助けてあげるという気持ちになるかと
だからどうせどうせ人間というのは
人が苦労になっていることは何とかします
それは何とかするということで
故に自分の命はもう惜しまないで
人の命を助けてあげるということはあまり言って欲しくないんです
それはちょっともうものの野心
知見というか この世に住まぬ力がないんだから言っていることで
まあできれば人を助けてあげたいんです
人を助けてあげたんだぞという自分の充実感
喜びっていうのはものすごくあるんです
この人を助けてあげます
それで私も死にますよということになると
手が動かない可能性はいくらでもあります
で それでまあもう最後なんですけど
まあお釈迦様の出来事なんですけど
世の中で一番可愛いのは何なのかと
という質問にお釈迦様は何の疑問もなく
ためらうこともなく自分だよと
世の中で一番可愛いのは自分だよ
自分ほど可愛いものはないんだと
まあそれは違いますよとみんな言いたがっていたんだけど
やっぱりお釈迦様の智慧にはもう勝てっこはないんだからね
結局私たちは自分というものが一番可愛いんだから
全部やってるんですよ
だから価値順番の 1 になっているのは自分ですよ
それも決まっています
ですから 自分のためになる順番なんですよ
だからリスト作ったところで
すごい気持ち悪くなるはずなんです
正しく作ったならば 価値の順位一番私のこと
には子供たちと書くかもしれません
なぜならば 私にとってはそいつらがすごい楽しいということになるんです
もしその子供たちがすごい嫌で
もうものすごくもう精神的な
もうもうもうなんて言いますか
ハイパーテンションでいろいろトラブル起こるんだったら捨てますからね
世の中で 子供を産んでそのまま逃げるお母さんたちもいるでしょうに
でも結婚していて 夫婦は決して子供を産んでは捨てません
なぜか その場合は家族としてそれが楽しみなんです
子育ては自分の遊びなんです
ゲームなんです だから自分がゲームしながら子供はコンピューターゲームやると怒るんです
だって母親にとっては子供を叱りながら子供の面倒を見ることはえらい楽しいゲームですから
子供にとってはそれはもう被害者だからね
楽しいわけじゃない だから子供はコンピューターゲームでもやらないと
ですから 家族が大事 子供が大事と言ったっても
これは自分に何か楽しみ
幸福感を作ってくるんだからなんです
なんでこの耳に指に首に足にあっちこっちに透けているこの金属が
価値があるんでしょうかというと
私ってかわいいでしょうとかね
自己満足できるんだからね
これ似合うでしょうとかね
似合いますよと 似合わなくても言わなくちゃいけないしね
別に金属に価値があるわけじゃないんですよ
包丁にはもっと価値があるんですけど
私の姪がすごいすごいいいことを言ったんだけど
もう彼女はまあ学問的にはエンジニアなんですけど
仕事はしないんだけどね
もう結婚して で お寺にこの間来たんですね
だから他の人々にはなんとかなんとか必要なちょっとしたプレゼントとかあったんだけど
この子には何もなかったんですね
考えても何も思い出さなかった
何かあげようかなとかね
で 寺に来て まあまあ 子供と一緒にね
まあみんなたくさん来たんだけど
そこでいろいろ何か必要な
この学校に来てる人とか
なんとか言って 他の人々には何もないなとかね
だってあんた方何も言わないんだから
何か必要なものあるかないかと言ったら
あの子言うのはね 私にね
まあ包丁でしょうね 価値があるなと
それしか何もないよと
うん だからそれ見てやっぱりさすがだなと思ったんですよ
だからもういくら勉強してでもいろいろあったっても
仕事は全部辞めましたし
辞めたというも まあ結構収入あった仕事あったんですよ
仕事を上げた側からも何回も何回も来て
来て 来てとかね 辞めないでくれと頼んだんですね
かなり明るい子で でも彼女はいい
子供には母親の愛情が必要だと
こんな仕事をなんかしてね
子供にとっては寂しい思いはしたくないよと
だから私は子供のために
子供はもうために全部もう切り捨てちゃったり
辞めますということで辞めちゃったんですね
それでだったら必要な包丁
私には何も要りませんよ
包丁さえあればいいやということで
だからこの それはもうしっかり考えてるところやと思いますけどね
まあだからこの なんでこの金属に価値があるかというと
まあなんか可愛く見えるんだという
それでなんとなく自己満足できると
これぐらいのことで ですから
我々はものに価値を入れようとするならば
一つ覚えておいてください
命に命を支えてくれるかないかという
だって必ずしも死ぬんですよ
だからずっと頑張って死なないようにカラカラしなくちゃいけないんですね
ご飯食べることも同じことで
食べなかったら死んじゃいますからね
ですから あの 大体人間が生きている限り価値があるのはこの命を支えてくれるものなんです
そこは他のものは全部ゴミで
もう高慢見栄ばっかし
差別感ばっかり作ってきて
作ってくれても世界の平和が壊すんですよ
だから逃げる時とか避難する時とかはね
命を守るものだけ持っていけばいいんです
ダイヤのネックレスよりおにぎり一向に価値がある時もありますからね
だから昔も今も食べ物には一応価値があるんですよ
それでまた欲を欲 もうもうかようではないかといって
もう食べ物 を作ることは商売にしてしまって
それで毒を作っている
今美味しいものは食べられない状態で
食べたことはないんだから
今あるあれは美味しいと思っているしね
だから自然の中でできたものっていうのを食べてみたらね
もう例えば自然の水とかね
いろいろこの工場で過程しなかった水なんかすっごい美味しいんですよ
飲んだことはないってことだから
ご飯でもね ものすごく自然の中でもう栽培しちゃうとすごい美味しくて香りがあって
たくさん食べなくてもっていいんですよ
ほんのちょっと食べるとすごい満腹感が出てきて
この果物 野菜 それぞれみんな独特の香りまだ持ってますよ
その香りもこのすごい精神的な安定剤になるんですよ
今は全部殺してるんです
この人工栽培だから香りがないんです
トマトを嗅いでトマトやと言えますかね
トマトはここら辺に 1個 2個いたら
あっちからでも言えるぐらいのトマトは自分の香りを持ってます
自然のトマトだったら
まあとにかくそんなもので
まあこれも人間の余計な欲で
もう金儲かることになってるんだから
我々は今毒食べることになっていてという風にもう全てもう壊れていくんでしょうし
ですから 我々は命を支えるものにはやっぱりずっと価値があるんだよというふうに理解した方がいいんですね
でも そんなものあったっても
人間にとってはやっぱりどうしても死ぬんだから
結局水の泡なんですよ
だから いくら食べて いくら工夫して生き延びても死にますよ
だから 今まであなたの努力は何なのかというと
全部水の泡なんです 今まで食べたご飯も
した運動も 着た服も住んでいた家も
何一つ役に立たないで死んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから その価値もやっぱり一時的なんですね
例えばご飯に価値があるのは
お腹が空いている時だけで
病気になってご飯を食べられない時
食べてはいけない時はご飯には価値がないんですよ
その時でも命を優先にしてみると価値が消えちゃうんです
自分の足に価値がありますけど
もし足にがんとかね 何か治らない病気とかだったら
足を捨てなくちゃいけないことになるんです
そういう場合は足の価値消えちゃうんですね
そこで仏教でいうのは
本当の価値っていうのは
この生きるということは心の機能なんですよ
この物体の中で心が機能している
だから心を育てることは何よりも価値があるんだと
それは消えませんと 死んでも生まれ変われる場合は
心のエネルギーで生まれ変われるんだからね
心は新しい体を形成しますから
その心をすごい綺麗で力強く持ちなさいよと
ある北九の芸文で これはあのシンハラ語になってヴィチェスとなりますけど
ヴィジェス まああの  4 44ですけど
質問がありまして こう今こうイマンパテヴィンウィチェッティ
誰がこの地球をもう理解する？ウィチェスとは理解するということになりますけど
ウィジェッティというバリアント読み方もあります
ウィジェスというのは誰がこの地球を勝ち抜きますか？という
まあだから誰がこの地球を支配して管理できるかというふうな言ってもいいし
それだけじゃない ヤマローカンチャイマンサデーヴァカン
死後の世界 この世の中
天国 ありとあらゆるものは勝ち抜く人って誰ですか？と
支配できる人って誰ですか？と
で それに質問 お釈迦様の答えは成功
パタウィンウィチェッティ
成功 この努力する人 成功っていうのはこの修行者ということなんですけど
お釈迦様がおっしゃった通りに
この心をきちんと明晰にしようではないかと
物事の判断を正しくしようではないかというように
そうマネジメントされて考えようではないかという
これ簡単ではありませんよ
もう完璧な怠け者だから
それは一つ一つなくしていかなくちゃいけないんだから
今までの習慣 習慣 概念
ありとあらゆる固定概念を捨てるということは
もう並ならぬ大変な仕事なんです
だから それやる人がすべて勝ち抜きますよと
あの世もこの世も天国も何だかんでも
もう勝っても関係ない
もう支配するっていうふうなことになるんですね
成功 ダンマパダにすべきした
クソロプッパミはパチェッティ
それで心を育てるためにお釈迦様がね
やっぱり体のことでもね
そんなに価値入れてはあかんと
もう我々は体のことで価値を入れてますけど
あの テーノーパマンカーヤミマン
この体はこの泡の塊だと見てくださいと
泡でできているものだと
そうするとすぐ弾けて弾けていくでしょう
だから弾けるんだから
また泡を作らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから体っていうのはそんなもので
このもうシャボン玉の塊のように
下からずっと吹いていると
シャボン玉がどんどん出てくるんだけど
また弾けて弾けていく
で やがてもう全部消えてしまう
ですから そのそればっかりやっていたっても意味がないんだから
やっぱりこの 頑張って心育ててくださいと
そこで人々っていうのは
そういう固定概念に溺れて
この乱れた湾曲された価値観に悩まされて
百年生きていたっても意味がないんだよと
一日でも真理を知って生きているならば
それこそ素晴らしいや
で 法華経の百十二番言います
ヨーチェワッササタンジーウェイジーウェークスィートヒーナウィルヨ
誰かが百年間生きていても
クスィート怠け者で努力することをしないで
いわゆる我々の普通のありのままの生き方なんです
あの日本で生活しているありのままの生き方なんです
そのありのままの生き方で
百年間生きていたっても意味がない
エーカーハンジービタンセイヨ
一日生きていたっても
ヴィリアランボーダルハン
ヴィリアランブッとダルハン
この努力して励みながら
真理のために一日生きたって
そちらに価値があるんだよと
で そういういろいろ教えがたくさんありますけどね
で 物に価値がないということで
私はこのすべてのものはゴミだと理解しなさいよと
体も単なる生ゴミだと理解しなさいとはもう散々言っているし
テキストも一つ書いてはありますから
これは機会に合わせてそれを読んでもらいたいんですね
もうただのゴミやと 生ゴミやと
これはスティーラの言い方じゃないんです
スマナサーラの大胆な言い方やと
それスマナサーラばっかり
それはブッダの教えなんです
それぐらい勇気出してほしい
勇気ってのは それ事実ですよ
体 単なる生ゴミ 臭い そんなものに価値を入れてはいけませんと
すべて捨てましょうと
捨てれば捨てれば楽だと
というのはブッダの道なんですね
だから価値論と言ったっても
価値がないということがブッダの教えなんです
なぜ価値がないかというと
一時的だからなんです
シャボン玉なんですよ
シャボン玉きれいきれいだといくら言っても価値がない
すぐ弾けちゃうんです
だから世界すべてシャボン玉より早く消える
ですね それなのに私たちはずっと価値がある
価値があると思っちゃうと悩み
苦しみが出てくる 二十歳ぐらい
三十代 四十代までは金のネックレスは価値があるかもしれません
その女性がどんどん八十歳になって
あるいはものすごい病気になって寝たきりになったっても
それで意味があるんでしょうかね
それでももうもう例えばもうもうもうもう末期状態になったっても
これネックレスをじっと握っちゃって
これには価値があるんだ
死ねないでしょうに だから手術台に持っていったら
そんなものを全部外しちゃうでしょうね
寝たきりになるとか 看病する人々は自分の都合でいろいろ
もう自分の高価な服ではなくて
もう適当な服着させちゃうでしょうに
価値消えちゃいますよ
その時 私はブランドのものしか着た着たことがないんだからと
そんな思いはないんですよね
その時は ですから 価値っていうのはもう入れちゃうと苦しいんです
バーミヤン の例言いますけど
もし仏教の人々がバーミヤン仏像様っていうのは大変ありがたいことで
この上のありがたいものやと思ってしまえば
大変な苦しみが生れるでしょうね
戦争しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますから
その人々と これは聖なるものやとか何とか思っちゃうと
だからこのラデンが怒っているのは
このサウジアラビアにアメリカ軍隊がいるんだという話だそうですね
聖地を汚しているんだと
ただの土地でしょうに
砂漠でしょうに 何の聖地ですかね
そういう価値を入れてるんだから
世界の我々苦しんでいるでしょうに
なんで価値入れるんですか？なんでイスラム人がみんなカバというなんとかのサウジアラビアのメッカを見てお祈りするんですかね
神がそちらに住んでいるんですかね
自分のコーランの教えにさえも反しているでしょうに
神は遍在しているんだから
どこにもあるんだから
便所を見てお祈りしていてもいいでしょうに
だって遍在でしょうに
ではない みんなメッカを見てメッカに価値を入れる
だからサウジアラビアには誰も入ってはいけないんです
入ったところで それはもうもう聖地を汚しちゃったと
それぐらいで汚す 聖地は聖地ですかね
誰かが入っただけで汚されると
汚れになると言って聖地じゃないんだからね
日本の伊勢神宮もそうでしょうに
入れてくれないでしょうに
汚れるんだと だったら行く必要ないんです
ろくな神じゃないんです
すごいというのはもうそんな
そんなことで汚れませんということでしょうに
例えば金はすごい金属ですよ
錆びませんね いくら踏ん張っても
でも銀は弱いんですね
金よりは格が低いでしょうね
ちょっとしたことで錆びちゃうんです
金はもうどこに置いておいたっても
もう錆びはしません だから価値があるんで
その点ではね 金属の中で王様やと
王様だから汚すよって言っちゃったらおかしいでしょうに
王様だから振っても蹴ってももう伸ばしても大丈夫ですよ
金だけいくらでも薄く伸ばすことできるできるんだから
伸ばしたところでこんな風になったっても価値があるんですよ
また溶かしちゃえばいいんだから
だから金属の王様なんですよ
正真正銘の でも我々拝んでる神様は何なのかというと
メッカのサウジアラビアに他の人が行っただけで汚れる
汚れるんです 伊勢神宮に他の一般の人が中に入っちゃったら
とんでもないことなんです
だから このくだらない人間の無知の考え方から
この価値を入れてるんだから
みんなお互いに殺し合いやって苦しんでるんですよ
死ぬ時も死ねなくなっちゃうんですよ
このお家に価値があるんだ
この店に価値があるんだとかね
子供にまで迷惑をかける
もうどうせ倒産寸前の店かもしれませんだけど
死ぬ前に親が約束させちゃうんですね
もう君はとにかくこの店をもう頑張って維持してほしいやと
これはもう代４代目まで続けている
もう看板が だから商売にならなきゃ
それは壊しちゃえばいいでしょうに
だから親の最後の約束だからといって
子供まで苦しむことになっちゃうでしょうに
だからそういうものには価値がないんですよ
言葉に価値があるのは真理の言葉だけなんです
親があなたは死ぬまで嘘をつくなよと言ったならば
その言葉には価値があるんです
親が死ぬ直前に 家を守りなさいとかね
そんなものは価値があるわけじゃない
それは世界のものだから
だからこうやってこの余計なものに価値を入れて
人間というのはいろいろ苦しんではいます
ですから無価値ですよと
...ないんだよと すべて無常だよと
瞬間だよと 変化するんだよと
あなたも変化する もう世界も変化するんだよと
それをわかった人は一切の価値観から心を解放して
完全たる解脱平安というのを味わいますよと
だから道を歩めば すべての人々は平和に豊かになるとは思います
なることは確実なんです
やってないだけのことなんです
そういうことで このものに価値があるということは
自分はかわいいということから出てくるんです
でも 自分というものは泡のごとく考えちゃうと
泡ですよと弾けているんだよと言ったら
自分でも何が可愛いかとなくなっちゃうんですよ
ずっと自分が変化して
年取ってもう醜くなっていくんだから
醜くなる分はいいんだ
いい それだけでも我慢できますけど
体がどんどん痛くて もう不自由で歩けないわ
もう階段登れないわ 腰が痛いとかいろいろ出てくるんだから
もう迷惑もいいところでしょうね
そんなものを可愛いと思うべきかと
年取って醜くなったっても
気楽に生きていられるんだったら
体が軽くていいんですけど
それはまあ そういう健康な人も確かにいますけど
それは多数派じゃないんですよ
すごい少数派なんです
多数派は腰が痛いはもうもう体がどんどん前に登る
女性の場合は前に曲がっちゃいますけど
男性の場合はもっとひどいんですよ
年取ってくると女性よりも体がボロボロで
だからどうせ早く死んじゃうし
だからまあそういう体にも価値入れてはいけないと
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する人々もうまくいかないのは
この価値の問題なんですね
すぐようにそのまなずかるではなくて
いろんな変なことを考えても
価値をもうもう何といいますか
湾曲しちゃう それで 1 日 2 日で成功するはずの瞑想が
40年かかってもまだやっているんだよということになっちゃうんです
それぐらい危険なんですね
価値観というのは お釈迦様の時代では
話を聞いて悟って帰ったという話なんですけど
今日読んだストーリーなんですけど
ある貧しい人がいて もうもう乞食ですけど
それで体がもうもうもうもうすごい小さくて曲がってるんですね
生まれつきこの背中が曲がって生まれた奇形児ですよ
だからまあまあまあ乞食で生活していて
そこでその人がもうもうどうせ乞食ですけどね
お釈迦様が説法しているところを見た
大勢の人々がいるのは
大勢の人々が集まっているんだから
何か食べ物があるんじゃないかなと
ちょっともらって食べようかなと言って
乞食に行った 行ったらお釈迦様は喋り話しているんだから
みんな話を聞いてるんだからね
この仏教の仲間っていうのは
このお釈迦様が喋ると
みんなじーっと話を聞いてるんです
声も立たないで 喉も鳴らせないで
だからその統一性を見ると
誰でももうもうもう何とか言おうとはしないんです
ものすごい圧倒されるんです
それで彼もまあもうこれ終わったら何か食べ物をもらおうということで
まあそう 学問勉強とかあるわけじゃない
生まれつき乞食です それでお釈迦様は人々の顔を見たら
今日は誰が話を聞いてくれるかなと
見たらみんなありがたやで感じで話を聞こうとしているだけで
真剣ということはないんですね
見たら あの乞食がこの人何を言おうとしてるんでしょうかと興味持ってるんですよ
初めて見たんだから そこで
あっ この人が話を聞きたいんだよと
それでわかって その人の心に合わせてお釈迦様は説法したんです
お釈迦様説法を終われると
あの乞食が何の学問何もない
もう夜中に悟ったんです
お腹が空いて何か食べ物が欲しいといった人なんですけど
あの大勢の人々の中で
ただその人だけ その説法で悟り開くんでしょうに
そういう世界なのに それでお釈迦さんはその人で
その人はその瞬間からもう別に私は乞食で
なんとか身分が低いと
そんなもうもうない価値観消えちゃったんです
もうそちらで王様たちが言おうがもうが
大金持ちが言おうが もうもう全然価値観消えちゃったんだから
そこでさっさとお釈迦様のところに行って礼をして
よく分かりましたと お釈迦様が真っ暗闇で光を当てたような感じで
私に真理を教えてくれた
道に迷っている人に道案内するように
お釈迦様の説法も私にぴったしはめてしまったと
私はこれから真理を知った人の一人として
真理を体験した一人として
お釈迦様に報告いたしますと
言って 堂々と悟りを発表までして帰るんですよ
こんなことできると思いますか？あれほど上下関係激しい社会で
乞食なんかは家になんか入れてもくれない世界で
だから真理っていうのはそんなもんなんです
不可触民族やという人でも
仏教の真理に出会ったら
もうみんなに拝まれるんです
2  3人いたんだから この不可触民族で
もう全くもう村に入れてはくれないぐらいのカーストの人々
お釈迦様見たら この人々もかなり頭が鋭いやと
と言って説法して あんたね
そんな苦労しないで出家したらどうですかと
そしたら私みたいなもんはね
この社会に入れてくれないんだと
出家したくないという気持ちはないんだけど
社会にさえ入れてくれないんだと
では 私たち出家してあげたら
あんたどうします？ったらありがたいんだと
ったら出家して 一旦出家したんだから頑張りなさいよ
それで頑張って悟るんですよ
悟り入れたら お釈迦様はこの 80代の弟子の中に入れて
このもう一人の一人前の人間
聖者ですよ 言って 今まで社会に入れてくれなかった人のことは
王様でも何のことなく礼をする
足を触って礼をするということになるんですよ
だから真理こそ道なんですよ
勇者勝利の道なんです
お金でもダイヤでもなんでもないんですよ
ただ苦しみだけで 貧乏か豊かとか全然関係ないんです
男か女か 病気かないかとかね
そんなもうどうせ消える体でしょうに
ですから価値は真理にあるんですよ
真理知っちゃうと 世の中の価値一切絶対すべて消えちゃいますから
堂々としていられます
恐怖感ひとかけらもなくなっちゃうんです
恐怖感というのは この価値から生まれるんです
不安定なひとかけらもないので
何に不安ですか？悩みというのはひとかけらも
何に悩むんですかね 価値がなければ悩むこともないんだからね
だからそういうことでものの価値というところから理解していけば
ブッダの教えも理解できるだろうと思います
どうもありがとうございます
はい